physical and mental energy to me is the
greatest riches of human life
comedian speaks to the public in a way
that no other person does privilege is
toxic yeah it unsaddle II it really is
sadly he's an American comedian actor
director writer and producer he's best
known for portraying a semi-fictional
portrait of himself in the sitcom
Seinfeld in 2005 Comedy Central named
him the 12th greatest stand-up comedian
of all time he's Jerry Seinfeld and
here's my take on his top ten rules for
success rule number six is my personal
favorite I make sure to stick around
although to the anger for some special
bonus clips putting in a phenomenal
day's work to me is way better than you
know let's say you come into a little
chunk of money you didn't think you were
gonna get you know you just get some
dough and you go hey that's great
that's that is great I think money's
great but energy physical and mental
energy to me is the greatest riches of
human life
what I am good at and what every
comedian is good at is knowing how to
carefully manage an audience's attention
span and that is also the key to this
show for example I'll give you another
when the show was first cut together
again go back to that little scene with
the phone about net-a-porter just
talking to my wife julia says ask your
wife about this thing about net-a-porter
I go you know what I'm going to ask
right now and I take the phone and i
dial the phone and I and then just picks
up the phone and I go hi Jess I'm
sitting here with Julia I'm in the
middle we're actually right in the
middle of doing an episode she has a
question about NetApp or tape
do you mind can I can I ask you right
now are you busy okay all you got to get
rid of all that all of that goes because
it's just boring now it's not boring in
a TV series you can when you're watching
a TV series you're watching an episode
of a sitcom there's a story that you're
hooked on and there are characters and
this is going somewhere this thing is
going nowhere
so even that when they first cut it
together they even had me dialing no no
you can't have that
that microsecond is on the Internet is
that because the Internet is the most
brutal medium for attention span the
distance from your finger to that oft or
stop is it's you're holding it right
there
while you're watching things you know
how many times you see a video you go oh
that looks good I want to see that you
press it and then what 15-second
commercial no no no no no now you don't
get 15 seconds it's not that good like
amazon.com one-click ordering that's
where I got this idea they understood
two clicks I don't even want it anymore
I changed my mind
in between clicks
as a stand-up comedian you must master
that attention span dynamic of an
audience and then it's no different from
you know trying to do jokes for for
drunks in a nightclub at two o'clock in
the morning you've got to get their
attention and hold it so you spend your
life doing it and that's what you have
to do on the Internet mmm to survive
comedian speaks to the public in a way
that no other person does he talks about
things that we all see commercials and
things and it's it's special you mean
it's it's a unique podium being a
stand-up comic you have free range and
you don't even really have to make a
point but you have to relate to people
on a very personal level and I was
afraid I'm still afraid of losing that
because I think that's the key to how I
own sanity as well as my my continued
success it's a
is feeling to invent something where
there was no template there before you
yeah to figure it out I mean I remember
I told the idea to louis c.k and i said
what i have this idea of I'll hang out
with comedians and I'll I'll shoot it
and I'll cut it together with music and
coffee and I said what do I do with that
and he says you should you should charge
people a dollar to dodge everyone a
dollar you know and I didn't like that I
did nobody knew what to do I went I had
this remember had this big meeting at
CAA you know with there's really smart
digital people you know it was like 10
people in the room people I had read
about never met this is the guy he meets
with Zuckerberg every day this is way
out there you know like okay well I got
this idea and it seems like you know as
a person that people know I have a you
know I have an audience people know me
so we can get people to check it out and
the internet seems like a pretty fluid
medium I could put this thing on the
internet you know what what what do you
think I could do when they went
no idea you know and then I met with
these Facebook people and I met with
YouTube people although I mean a guy
like me you know that's one of the fun
things about being me is you can meet
believe you know
you can call anybody and say can I talk
to you and they go sure come on and they
and they are all smart and they were
nice and they were well-intentioned and
they all told me this will not work this
will not work if you they said if you're
over five minutes
nobody's gonna they're not going to hang
in there yeah because the Internet is
five minutes is the maximum length of
time and we average 19 minutes of viewer
so that was pretty cool
I think the breakthrough is when people
are talking about your act to other
people and they can't do it yeah you
know what I mean they start to do it and
they go I can't do it it's the way he
does it that it's so engrained in your
personality and the way you talk and the
way you behave that people cannot
imitate it how did you find it you just
you just I mean did you sit there and
say audience what can I talk about the
audience does the audience teaches you
over the years that's the way I learned
you just night after night show after
show after show you're doing something
and they laugh and you go why did they
laugh at that and but the next night you
do it again the same way if they left
and you then you build on it privilege
toxic yeah it unsaddle e it really sadly
things that people struggle to achieve
yeah they get your positions of power
influence money can do things it has a
toxic effect on their judgement yes has
that happened to you yet no why is that
do you think so yes yeah come on so you
do some more so you're a funny guy thank
you
you go on some late-night talk shows
people think you're funny yeah they give
you a show right and then next thing you
you know you've made like a ridiculous
amount of money so much more than you
and yet no how do I seem to you do I
seem what spoiled a lot of touch well I
don't know well you have a you know a
good instinct for people right now you
seem like a completely normal guy but
I'm putting on an act well that's like
everyone else does for you that's my
point
that's that's what I'm you're right but
I'm gonna probe this the question is how
did you calibrate dealing with that
right now at a certain point you might
have thought yourself you know what I'm
more than just a comedian yeah I'm gonna
make a Jewish version of Citizen Kane
you know how did you keep respect I'll
give you the real answer which it's
gotta be similar to your life I fell in
love with the work and the work so it
was joyful yeah and difficult and
interesting and that was my focus food
is so complicated as an adult that's
just where you see people in the
supermarket they're just sweating it out
nobody knows what do I eat that protein
the carbs and the fat content oh my god
that content I'm just walking up to each
other you look pretty good what are you
eating maybe I'll eat that
the whole supermarket itself is designed
to break down your sense of having any
life outside the supermarket it's like a
casino there's no clocks no windows no
easily accessible exits you ever not buy
anything in the supermarket and try and
get out of there it's impossible there's
no way out you can see what happens to
people when they're walking up to the
supermarket they really have a whole
sense of purpose I'm gonna get this I'm
gonna get bad I'm gonna pay for it I'm
gonna get out of here and you're right
back to my normal life you see that same
person ten minutes later just
what aisle is this why did I come up
here always noticing something new well
I got him in Mesquite flavor now what is
Mesquite wonderful made from mosquitoes
produce section I always find very
challenging is always some special thing
you're supposed to know you know about
each fruit summertime make sure your
peaches are I don't know whatever it is
you gotta fake it you know I'm shaking
stuff holding it up to the line yeah
that's a good one I'm sure glad I found
that one
cantaloupes roll them down the aisle see
the way that's fading left that one's
not ready I don't want that one very
impressed with this seedless watermelon
product that they have for us they've
done it
we now have seedless watermelon pretty
amazing what are they planting to grow
the seedless watermelon I wonder the
melons aren't humping are they they must
be plant or something
how does this work and what kind of
scientist do this type of work I read a
think was 15 years in development in the
laboratories with you know gene splicing
or whatever they do there I don't know I
mean other scientists working on AIDS
cancer heart disease these guys ago and
now I'm gonna devote myself to Mellon I
think that's much more important
sure thousands are dying needlessly with
this that's got to stop
you ever try and pick up a wet one off
the floor it's almost impossible I
really think we should devote the mind
to these studies milk is a big problem
for people in the supermarket they're
never quite sure if they have it if they
need it they bury it way in the back in
the supermarket you got to find it you
got to hack your way through all the
displays well yeah there it is there's
the milk do we have any mail people are
never really sure if they have no think
you have nope we might add I know
there's a carton in there I don't know
how much is it well what should we do
cuz you want to be sure there's nothing
worse than thinking you have milk I'm
not happy you know you got the bowl set
up the cereal the spoon the napkin the
TV the newspaper everything's ready to
go you're gonna lift up the cart and
it's too light huh oh no tonight or
sometimes you think you need okay we
better pick up some milk like many of
you were thinking right now
you know he's right maybe we should pick
up some so you'll pick up some milk on
the way home and then you'll discover
you already had milk and now you got way
too much milk that's no good either now
it's a race against the clock with the
expiration date that freaky thing now
you're eating giant punch bowls of
cereal three meals a day you're washing
your face with milk bringing cats in
from all over the neighborhood hurry up
and drink it come on it's almost time
get it back over here how do they know
that that is the definite exact day you
know they don't say like it's in the
vicinity give or take
roughly they brand it right into the
side of the car minute that's your
goddamn day right there
oh don't screw with us we know what day
is the final day and then it is so old
never have milk the day after the day
scares the hell out of you doesn't it
this spoon is trembling as it comes out
of the book it's after the day I'm
taking a big chance I smell it you smell
it was it supposed to smell like
smell like milk to me I don't know how
they're so definite though maybe the
cows tip them off when they're milking
them July 3rd
Oh
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Kenny mean asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
in the comments below I will see what I
can do
I'd also love to know which is Jerry
Seinfeld's top ten rules have the
biggest impact on you and why what
change you're going to make in your
business as a result of watching this
video what clip was your favorite leave
in the comments and I will join in the
discussion
finally we give a quick shout out to Dre
Baldwin from Dre allday.com Thank You
Jay for picking up a copy of my book if
you guys watching if you want to change
that a shadow in a future video make
sure to grab the book and email in your
receipt so we can keep track thank you
guys so much for watching continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
I'll see you soon
so with Letterman retiring that's
another one of your peers that was
retiring and I know you said you'll
never really stop doing stand-up but I
was wondering what drives you to do this
show like what did the things outside
standup like what is what is bringing
you to do that I I did this show I
really first of all I never thought it
was a show it was really actually just
very recently that I starting to think
maybe this is actually something yeah
but I kind of missed from talk shows the
funny talking of casually hanging out
yeah there's no casual hanging out
anymore on talk shows the real estate is
too valuable and people want to push
their product and and I don't know so I
came up with this idea of like if I ever
did a talk series I never did a talk
shows because I can't really talk to
people that aren't comedian yeah and be
funny it's hard you know you're doing
just great
it's only been three minutes yeah okay
so I don't know this was my personal
fantasy idea of what I would like to
watch and stand-up has become so popular
with so many young people now yeah
there's so many stand-up geeks you know
I thought they would they would like
this you know so I just made a few of
them and just threw them on the internet
we didn't do any press or yeah sell it
in any way and you know that's what's so
cool the internet fascinated me also as
a network I thought why do I need a TV
network why can't this is a network so
that was what drew me to it you want to
know the
key to comedy right now in two words
because you guys going to be doing more
comedy bits on the show
let let me explain the of the basic
thing really all you need to know loud
and fast
do not leave pauses between the lines
say it loud say fast and eight you're
80% there when people would come on the
show actors sometimes good actors they
would come on to do a scene or do a part
on the show that's all we would tell
them louder faster louder faster you
can't fix the the materials the material
right you're gonna do what and that was
that was pretty good
that was pretty good I thought I would
say a shish kebab you guys know I would
say I would make it 30 seconds shorter
and I would pull out some of the air the
did you edit that or was that just you
did edit it a little bit okay so I would
just pull that a little more air and I
thought it played pretty well the best
who who captured a character out of
these that they're they're all good well
that you were good Fritzie as as George
he was good you know I appreciate he
talked quickly he always does what about
in comedy you gotta talk quickly because
you want that you you want to get the
mind going